bien
en tijuana decenas de familias esperan
una respuesta de asilo humanitario en
eeuu una incertidumbre que el proyecto
de emergency cyrus trata de aliviar con
un circo itinerante de una entrega de
juguetes así que les traemos un poco de
alegría en nuestra manera de decir que
son bienvenidos que son valiosos como
personas y que no hay nadie que sea
ilegal reunido la organización ha
visitado fronteras de todo el mundo
pasando por áfrica y llegando hasta
italia su objetivo divertir por un rato
a aquellos que se encuentran varados en
una frontera que no conocen
[Música]
una medida desesperada de pandemia se ha
convertido en una solución comunitaria
si yo sacaría ingeniero aeronáutico de
22 años vivía en dubai la pandemia le
sorprendió en una visita a su familia en
que era la india entonces junto a su
padre recolectaron semillas de frutas y
verduras y siguieron las técnicas
transmitidas por su abuelo así logró
alimentar a 20 hogares vecinos
las tiendas se vaciaban schering no
tenían existencias y empezamos a
compartir comida guardamos las semillas
que nos daban y empezamos a enseñar a
otros a cultivar para que pudiesen tener
su propia huerta
winehouse sounds of hope during the land
tras su vuelta a dubai el huerto es
gestionado por la comunidad mientras que
zaccaría ha decidido cambiar su trabajo
con aviones por la jardinería
en malasia a mujeres refugiadas rojillas
tienen la oportunidad de aprender a leer
y escribir gracias a la asociación women
for the face una de las pocas
asociaciones centradas exclusivamente en
mujeres
chino era esencial para nosotros no
presentar a las mujeres refugiadas desde
la caridad y la necesidad de ayuda
externa
por eso queremos dotarlas de las
habilidades necesarias para que sean
autónomas y no dependan de nadie más
la organización ha reunido 20
voluntarios a través de un llamado por
la red social instagram un compromiso
con una decena de mujeres para que
puedan aprender inglés y malayo
madre de 5 y la primera mujer taxista en
territorio para destino a sus 39 años y
con un título en servicio comunitario
abusiva ha entrado en el negocio de los
taxis exclusivas para mujeres en gaza'
porque pensé en este proyecto para que
las mujeres se sientan cómodas soy mujer
y me gusta sentir confort verdad a pesar
de haber recibido comentarios sexistas
la iniciativa está triunfando entre las
mujeres por lo que lleva a espera poder
expandir pronto su negocio
el río cauca ya de bangkok en tailandia
tiene un servicio público de botes para
trasladar a sus ciudadanos unas
embarcaciones que a partir de ahora
serán eléctricas utilizando la energía
solar para eliminar las altas emisiones
contaminantes del diésel y
comprometiéndose así con el medio
ambiente
ah